what's up guys I'm zet and I'm doing a
Google autocomplete interview I'm doing
a Google complete its Google
autocomplete Google is said is that deaf
I'm not deaf I had a sudden hearing loss
once and I was deaf for a little bit
but I'm not deaf anymore pretty happy
about that to be honest with you is that
a boy or a girl
I think I'm a boy I understand the
question though because a lot of my
music is with female singers so if you
don't know you might assume it's my
voice is that a Russian or German I'm
German I have a German passport but I
was born in Russia so I'm a little bit
of both what is Zed's real name my real
name is Anton zhis laughs key the Z at
the end outside of America you say said
you know you see is liam payne's brother
I'm not liam payne's brother he's my
brother you know my brother but he's not
actually my brother I love him though
like a brother
thus Zed ever sing yes I do backing
vocals on almost all of my songs when
you hear a harmony or an O or a high
octave it's of them's gonna be me cuz
sometimes singers don't have enough time
but I've never done the lead vocal does
that have a tattoo I do not no tattoos I
want to get a dot here the one pixel so
next time I can say yes but I currently
don't does that speak German ich spreche
Deutsch I grew up in Germany so yes
definitely speak German does that play
League of Legends I did a song for
League of Legends but I think I would
suck at this game and if I play a game I
want to be the best at it and I'm not
gonna be the best of League of Legends
what does that mean it means absolutely
nothing has no meaning whatsoever it's
just my hey what is that like I work a
lot I work very hard but when I'm at
home I'm boring I don't want to move I
don't want to go anywhere and I want to
leave my house and just want to marinate
in a jacuzzi
what does that used to produce I produce
in Cubase I've used it since I was
really young since Cubase - I've tried
using Ableton once and I just don't
understand it because I'm so used to
Cubase I use Pro Tools to record vocals
to track him and to compound as soon as
the vocals comped I go back to Cubase
and produce and mix and master and
everything Incubus what's the meaning of
the song in the middle by Zedd well the
main line is why don't you just meet me
in the middle I'm sure you've been in a
situation where you had one opinion and
somebody else had another opinion and
all you want to do is just meet
somewhere in the middle what instruments
can Zedd play my first instrument is
piano that's what I used to write music
then I used to be drummer in a band I'm
probably better drummer than pianist and
I can't play enough guitar and bass to
record for my songs and that's it
how many languages can Zed speak I speak
Russian German English and I studied
French and I tried to forget everything
so I would say three and a quarter
how's that became famous I mean I don't
know I just made music and at some point
after decades somebody decided that my
music is nice and they like it and then
people started listening to it and I
guess that if you even want to call me
famous that's how I got famous how old
is it I'm 29 by the time you're watching
this I might be 40 so hurry up how did
that learn to produce well I used to be
in a band and we used to record bands so
I had to know how microphones work and
what compressors do and what eq's doing
how to cut out the stuff you don't want
to hear so when I started making
electronic music already kind of had the
knowledge and then I just had to figure
out how to use since and how to make
sounds and how to mix that's how I
learned to produce nobody taught me I
just trial and error until I was good
enough how many siblings does that have
I have an older brother who lives with
me and I have a younger half-brother who
lives in Germany who has Zedd worked
with why I'm sitting here and you may
have heard of me are all the incredible
singers that sing the songs with people
from Ariana Grande - Selena Gomez - John
belly into logic
to Marin Morris Alessia Cara I think we
don't have enough time to count about
who has that produced I've produced Lady
Gaga Justin Bieber thirty Seconds to
Mars
well I produce for Ariana a lot of
people sometimes when I don't want to
make music for myself I like to make
songs and give them to other people
because it's less pressure for me
because I hate being judged so this is
my way of escaping bad who designed Jets
house it's an architect called Marc whip
ler he's incredible thank you for being
so awesome who sings middle by Zed Maren
Morris she's an amazing person she's an
incredible singer Maren thanks for being
awesome
dear Internet thank you so much for
asking these questions of which some are
really interesting and some are really
bad but you want to know so thanks for
asking